c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir ce triste anniversaire
c'était il y a 20 ans le Djula sombré au
large du Sénégal le nombre de victimes
du naufrage du ferry dépasse celui du
Titanic nous reviendrons sur ce drame et
nous serons en direct avec le président
de l'association des victimes
l'inquiétude des organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme en Guinée
après l'arrestation d'un leader
politique il venait de critiquer le
pouvoir de transition à la radio nous
serons à Conakry dans ce journal et puis
l'ouverture du procès de ma matsaïd
abdelkani ex commandant rebelle présumé
de la CDK en Centrafrique il fait face à
sept chefs d'accusation entre autres
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité devant la CPI la Cour pénale
internationale il a plaidé non coupable
les détails dans ce jour
1863 morts c'est le lourd bilan du
naufrage du Djula le ferry sénégalais
qui a sombré au large de la Gambie il y
a 20 ans le navire avait une capacité
maximale de 500 passagers et pourtant ce
jour-là il y en transporté 2000 les
conditions météo et mauvaises et le
sauvetage pas à la hauteur reportage de
nos confrères de France 2
ce sont des images inédites voici le
jour là à sarcophage d'acier rongé par
la rouille
le ferry qui a coulé avec plus de 1800
personnes à bord bien plus que le
Titanic repose désormais sur du sable à
20 mètres de profondeur
ces hélices sont toujours bien visibles
certains hublots sont encore ouverts
plus loin dans ce chaos des véhicules
sont retournés
mais il y a aussi ses vêtements coincés
dans une poutre des bracelets des bijoux
féminins ainsi que de nombreux ossements
cette exploration exceptionnelle a été
réalisée par une équipe
franco-sénégalaise et la profondément
marqué se plongeur
il y avait des gens qui tapaient dans la
coque qui étaient encore en vie les
secours arrivent ils ont pas de moyens
techniques pour les sortir donc il les
entendus mourir et je me suis retrouvé
dans cette partie
ça repartir là où il y a voilà il y a
beaucoup de Semans quelques centaines
ont été retrouvés des corps qui ont été
amenés par les courants sur les plages
mais on est loin d'avoir retrouvé tout
le monde le jeu là était filmé quelques
heures avant son naufrage le navire est
bondé il accueille quatre fois plus de
passagers qu'autorisés et tank
dangereusement
partie de Casamance il doit rejoindre
Dakar dans la nuit mais vers 23h pris
dans une tempête le ferry surchargé ce
retourne piégant ses occupants seul 64
personnes survivront
a commencé à se passer du côté gauche
et j'ai plongé là maintenant ce n'était
plus assuré par l'armée et la surcharge
trop importante
la justice sénégalaise classera
l'affaire au bout d'un an rejetant toute
la responsabilité sur le commandant de
bord mort durant le naufrage un grand
mémorial actuellement en construction
sur place devrait accueillir les objets
remontés par l'équipe franco-sénégalaise
la question délicat des ossements
présents dans les Pavel reste toujours
sans réponse 20 ans après le naufrage
et une cérémonie s'est tenue ce lundi
matin en Casamance en mémoire des
victimes en présence des familles mais
aussi d'officielles pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec boubacarba
président de l'Association des familles
des victimes de jula bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir un
procès on l'a entendu 20 ans après que
ressentez-vous et qu'attendez-vous
aujourd'hui de la justice
voilà d'abord aujourd'hui ça a été un
moment très émouvant pour nous 20 ans
après pour parler du diola pour
commémorer encore une fois mais ce
sentiment que nous avait toujours c'est
ce sentiment d'injustice qui nous habite
mille l'avait dit plus de 2000 morts
pratiquement et que nous sommes encore
là et donc aujourd'hui malgré tout ce
que les tentatives qui ont été menées
par les différentes associations aussi
bien ici qu'en France
franchement il n'y a plus pas de suite
vraiment nous rééditons nous pensons
qu'il faut réouvrir le dossier du diola
pour l'intérêt de tout le monde et voilà
ce que nous nous sentons et surtout
renforcer le bateau renforcer le bateau
parce que c'est une question de dignité
humaine dans notre sociologie nous ne
pouvons pas admettre
un sanctuaire marin nous ne pouvons pas
admettre parce que ça fait pas partie de
notre sociologie ici pratiquement il y a
des gens qui ne se rendent pas compte
jusqu'à l'heure actuelle qu'ils ont eu
peur et à perdre des âmes des proches
parce que simplement on n'a pas eu de
corps moi-même qui vous parle concernant
mon frère son fils mon oncle le matin on
n'a pas retrouvé l'école et donc ce qui
nous motive davantage sur la question du
renflement et la question de la justice
alors est-ce que vous
êtes il est clair que on a vu ailleurs
révolte des dossiers même si on nous dit
après prescription dans le cas d'espèces
mais nous pensons que volontairement il
faudrait qu'on aille c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde parce que
dans tous les accidents que ça soit
avion au bateau le premier réflexe c'est
c'est pour les avions c'est la boîte
noire pour savoir quelle est la route
d'origine de ce drame et je pense que
tout le monde intérêt parce que nous ne
sommes pas à l'abri de notre dollar
parce que simplement on n'a pas compris
cette histoire parce que on n'a pas
aussi fait ce qu'il fallait faire pour
qu'on soit à l'abri de telle catastrophe
et donc nous avons toujours
le vraiment le sentiment que un jour
viendra et bien jusqu'à la fête alors
vous parlez tout à l'heure des
sépultures des corps on a vu dans le
reportage de nos confrères de France 2
qu'il y a encore des ossements qui sont
enfouis est-ce que vous avez l'espoir
qu'on les repêche et que surtout que ces
ossements soient identifiés pour que les
familles puissent avoir une sépulture
oui vous savez nous on a fait une
proposition à l'époque avec le président
Word dans le cas d'une nouvelle
définition de renflement il s'agit donc
de sortie tous les RS humaines d'en
faire une tombe commune comme à bassori
vous savez en Gambie on va à basse aussi
mais c'est un lieu de mémoire et le
reste faire
soulever un mât vers la côte de
kafontaine et en faire un lieu de
recueillement voilà ce que nous avons
proposé dernièrement avec l'état du
Sénégal mais bon on en est là c'est tout
simplement on peut pas évoluer donc j'ai
quand même l'impression il y a un
dialogue ressources entre nous et l'état
du Sénégal alors est-ce que ce terrible
drame a servi de leçon ou en sont
aujourd'hui les normes de sécurité des
ferries
alors vous savez d'ailleurs dans dans
mon discours d'aujourd'hui j'ai attiré
l'attention à la classe politique que
nous sommes embarqués dans un autre
navire qui s'appelle le navire Sénégal
et que parfois nous avons des soucis
nous en tant que famille victime quand
on voit lesquels intempestives entre les
différentes
parties et autres et que le Sénégal
restera au Sénégal doit être unis sur
l'essentiel et c'est pour cela
l'introspection est de mise parce que
nous devons réfléchir c'est un dollar
qui nous a alerté pour dire que de
changer nos comportements et c'est
l'occasion qu'on voulait avoir avec le
président Macky Sall aujourd'hui et les
différents responsables politiques
autour malheureusement il n'était pas là
ni ni de Macky Sallan
nous pensons que la meilleure manière
c'était aujourd'hui 20 ans après pour
que tout le monde Converse ici au port
afin de de sacraliser un minimum de
consensus parce que les tiraillements
vraiment le Sénégal en Omar il s'agit
d'un pays il s'agit d'aller de définir
un cap d'espérance et ce qu'on voit ce à
quoi on a tous sa femme nous fait peur
en tant que citoyen et c'est pour ça
l'introspection est une valeur que nous
voulons incarner et nous sommes des
sentinelles en tant que victime parce
que ce qui nous arrive ici nous on n'a
pas de vie en tant que famille de
victimes depuis 20 ans moi je ne sens
pas le temps passé c'est comme si vous
me dites hier l'audio là sombré donc
raison pour laquelle nous alertons les
autres citoyens vu ce qui est sacré
c'est à dire la vie humaine et dans ce
sens là j'ai vu l'autre semaine il y a
eu 20 morts dans une journée personne
n'en parle mais alors c'est comme une
sorte de banalisation de la mort qui
nous habite qui nous hante et c'est pas
bon pour un pays alors vous l'avez dit
le président Macky Sall n'était pas là
Ousmane Sonko non plus est-ce que vous
avez un message à leur faire passer
oui surtout surtout pour dire que avant
tout nous sommes des Sénégalais le
Sénégalais ne sont pas des ennemis entre
eux nous sommes des sénégalais avant
tout et que pour pour le bien de tout le
monde pour une vie en commune en commun
autant pour moi c'est quand même un
minimum de savoir-vivre or ce que la
classe politique monte aux citoyens
n'est pas la voix à suivre il y a une
tension perpétuelle ici chez nous qui
fait que on n'est pas l'abri d'une de
l'étincelle qui va je ne souhaite pas
qu'il va tout bousiller et donc rappeler
aux citoyens ce qui nous arrive c'est le
nous sommes embarqués dans un navire je
le répète qui est le Sénégal nous
souhaitons pas qu'il y ait des
similitres en ce qui s'est passé ces 26
septembre 2002 où tout le monde parce
que simplement on a une attaque sur la
transgambienne et que tout le monde a
rué vers nos portes parce qu'il y avait
pas d'autres perspectives pour aller à
Dakar et tout le monde c'est rué sur ce
navire là et bon avec les complaisances
on se retrouve que 2000 morts et voilà
ce qui a conduit au naufrage et donc
nous pensons que une il y a un minimum
de sérénité qu'on qu'on demande à nos à
nos dirigeants de tout bord et qu'on
puisse aller droit devant vers quelque
chose de comment c'est ça la vérité et
qu'on nous disait pas le Sénégal a des
opportunités extraordinaires de faire du
Joola comme leur Rwanda en a fait des
drames et aujourd'hui ils sont mis dans
un cadre positif donc nous nous
réclamons de positiver l'audio là il
faut positiver le dialogue pour définir
un cap un minimum de savoir-vivre entre
nous en tant que citoyens merci beaucoup
votre message est passé merci président
de l'Association des familles des
victimes de Djula et merci à Sarah Sakho
qui nous a aidé à réaliser ce duplex
merci beaucoup
cette arrestation en Guinée Étienne Soro
pour Guy leader politique a été arrêté
pour avoir critiqué la transition au
pouvoir des gendarmes lourdement mais
attendez à la sortie de la radio où il
venait de s'exprimer son avocat dénonce
une arrestation arbitraire et les
organisations de défense des droits
humains se disent inquiète la
correspondance à Conakry de Malik
Diakité selon plusieurs témoins
l'opposant a été arrêté à sa sortie
d'une émission radio de grande écoute
avant d'être conduit à la gendarmerie en
banlieue de Conakry au cours de cette
émission Étienne soropoguy avec qualifié
oh je cite de dérive autoritaire de la
gestion de la transition par les
militaires au point tout ton critiquant
des interpellations de journalistes de
personnalités politiques et acteurs de
la société civile son avocat dénonce en
une arrestation en justes et arbitraire
il n'a jamais fait l'objet d'une
poursuite il n'a jamais reçu une
quelconque convocation il a été guetté
à sa sortie d'une émission animée par la
radio FIP il a été pourchassé et
interpellé au niveau de qui peut là où
il était parti rendre visite à sa
famille nous voulons que je suis soit
rendu et qu'il soit purement et
simplement remis en liberté selon
plusieurs ONG de défense des droits de
l'Homme la situation des droits humains
en devient très inquiétante en Guinée il
y a des signaux inquiétants en matière
de droits de l'homme et comme vous le
constatez depuis un certain temps il y a
quand même des pratiques qui étaient là
avant le 5 septembre qui commence à se
reproduire sur le terrain notamment le
fait de d'arrêter les gens et mano
military et sans que en tout cas qu'il y
ait des convocations préalables il y a
beaucoup d'avertissements qui sont
aujourd'hui lancés au niveau des acteurs
des médias il y a des médias qui sont
suspendus bien sûr nous sommes dans une
période transition mais la transition ne
voudrait pas dire quand même qu'il faut
mettre des côtés les droits de l'homme
en Guinée depuis juin plusieurs
opposants sont incarcérés à la prison
centrale de Conakry en attente de leur
procès notamment des leaders du Front
national pour la de la Constitution
il fait à deux jours de l'ouverture du
procès du massacre et des viols commis
au stade de Conakry le 28 septembre 2009
l'ancien dictateur Moussa Dadis Camara
est rentré en Guinée pour répondre de
ses accusations devant le tribunal avec
10 autres accusés nous suivrons bien
évidemment la tenue de ce procès dans le
journal de l'Afrique et sur France 24
cette autre procès cette fois la Haye
devant la Cour pénale internationale
l'excommandant rebelle présumé de la
seleca en Centrafrique mahammat Saïd
abdelkani a comparu ce lundi devant le
tribunal à l'ouverture de son procès et
il a plaidé non coupable compte-rendu
d'audience avec Stéphanie Maupas notre
correspondante à La Haye
premier jour de ce procès le procureur a
détaillé les éléments dont il disposait
dans son dossier pour pouvoir démontrer
prouver que Saïd abdelkani a bien commis
les crimes qui lui sont reprochés vous
savez quand il était à la tête de
l'océab à l'office de répression du
banditisme et bien il aurait détenu un
certain nombre de personnes dans des
conditions absolument effroyables et ces
personnes et bien certains d'entre eux
auraient été battus et d'autres torturés
voilà un peu les éléments à présenter
aujourd'hui le le bureau du procureur
alors à l'ouverture de cette audience et
bien Saïd abdelkani a déclaré qu'il
plaidait non coupable un des sept chefs
d'accusation de crimes contre l'humanité
et de crime de guerre la parole sera
demain à la défense et la suite du
procès la semaine prochaine avec
l'audition des premiers témoins
en bref sachez que le secrétaire général
de l'ONU a appelé lundi dans un
communiqué à la libération immédiate des
46 soldats ivoiriens détenus au Mali
depuis début juillet
et avant de se quitter cette triste
nouvelle Aïcha Chenna surnommé la Mère
Teresa du Maroc n'est plus la militante
marocaine des droits de l'homme et
décédé à Casablanca à l'âge de 81 ans
des suites d'une longue maladie elle
s'est longtemps battue pour la cause
féminine et entre autres pour les mères
célibataires au Maroc que la terre lui
soit légère
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24